Earlier this week Council held its monthly
meeting for April.
With the Draft Long Term Plan currently in
public consultation, it’s a busy time for
Council and there was a large agenda to get through.
The Council works closely with Te Ngāi Tūāhuriri Rūnanga on many significant issues around our district.
A proposal was made that a seat with voting rights be made available on the District Planning
and Regulation Committee, in order that the
Rūnanga could contribute to a review of the
Waimakariri District Plan.
Although this motion was narrowly defeated,
the Council will continue to look at ways
it can partner with Ngāi Tūāhuriri to develop
our district.
Council appointed Councillors Atkinson, Meyer
and Doody to the hearing and deliberations
panel for the review of the local Alcohol
Policy and the hearing and deliberations panel
for Liquor Ban Bylaw review.
These hearings are scheduled to take place
over July.
The Council also formally adopted the final
Waimakariri District Development Strategy,
Our District, Our Future – Waimakariri 2048.
This document was presented to the community
last year for feedback and will help guide
our growing district’s development over
the next 30 years.
Councillors also had to consider a number
of complex water and wastewater infrastructure
issues and as a result.
Brought forward funding for improving wastewater
services in the Tuahiwi area.
Brought forward funding and approved staff
proceeding with physical works on the upgrade
of the Oxford Rural No. 1 water scheme while
waiting for a resource consent to be granted.
And approved a new budget for drainage work
in Springbrook in order to mitigate flooding.
The Councillors also planned for the upcoming
Anzac Day commemorations and they will attend
the following services across the district:
The next monthly Council meeting will be at
the Council Chambers in Rangiora on Tuesday
1st of May at 1pm.